roughly one year after the initial
launch of its online RPG the crew
Ubisoft has now released the wilderun
expansion which like the original is
bursting with engaging wilderun fills
out the face game's cooperative
cross-country racing with motorcycles
monster trucks dragon drift builds new
licensed vehicles dynamic weather visual
upgrades throughout game wide physics
adjustments and a massive ongoing online
competition called the summit
unfortunately execution once again
undermines ambition while the handling
physics in general visuals have
undoubtedly improved they still haven't
caught up with other racing games like
the mechanically robust quartz ax when
the visually slick Need for Speed still
drifting Brad expects add even more
variety to the crews already impressive
collection of race types while the
monster trucks and the massive skatepark
arenas that come with them inject some
goofy fun in spite of all the new
content however many of the base game's
frustrations persist the UI is an
unintuitive mess the story is still
laughably bad and finding players to
join my crew frequently took longer than
it should have as a result the crew as a
whole remains a lackluster experience
even with its monster truck half pipes